all right thanks everyone for the coffee
break
we're happy to help Kiba kazuto-sama on
just been doing great work in
differential privacy for a long time now
thanks Evan so yeah my name is Chewbacca
shoosh not then I guess it's great to
talk about this topic here because I
think there's a topic that I first heard
right in this room about five years back
when I think we had first workshop on
privacy Benjamin II give a talk on false
discovery and you think about it for
five years but just recently we thought
about it again and joined work with my
intern the problem that we are going to
discuss about is false discovery which
is been in the news lately I mean it's a
very important problem in the scientific
community because it it's what we
believe to be true or false because and
so controlling false discovery is a
really important problem especially when
you want to get to valid statistical
hype things the problem has been is very
important because in modern scientific
analysis we have lots of hypothesis
tests that's that's weird even carrying
out because if you think of a typical
microarray experiment that is common all
right in DNA sequencing is that we carry
more than 10,000 tests for each
microarray and what happens when you do
as so many tests is the chance of
spurious discoveries and false discovery
so let's run through a simple example to
see what what is mean by false discovery
so let's say that be running 10,000
independent statistical tests let's for
simplicity assume that nine thousand
nine hundred another of them are
actually negative sign hundred of the
bad posture so this is the ground truth
so ninety nine hundred of them are
negatives 100 of these tests are
positive let's say that we said you
alpha the significance level of these
stairs to be point out five
or so I take nine hundred nine thousand
nine hundred times but not by that 495
so you you cook it about four ninety
five false identifications and let's say
the power of these tests that you have
is really great it's eight eighty which
is really high number so you get 80 of
them true positives of one hundred if
you look at the ratio of these things
and a number of the false this Kebede
divided by the number of total
discoveries that's four ninety five
divided by four ninety five plus eighty
that's a number that's really close to
one so notice that this is not a problem
with the test being independent on each
other it just happens even if the tests
are independent if the data is
independent and so on so this is not a
problem with the test being dependent on
each other it's just a problem that we
are running soon eaters so that's the
problem when you run multiple tests so
that's the question is how do you
control for the various discoveries in
the setup so this is a problem that's
been there for many decades but it was
kind of formalized in a DVD plus I sense
by Benjamin Hochberg who introduced this
notion of false discovery rate control
and introduce a notion that that is used
to control false discoveries we need to
multiple hypothesis testing
this wasn't offline setting about 10
years ago Foster and Stein introduced
this notion of online fault to scurry
raid control which added which moved the
setting from offline to an online
setting but this work is about
I think another prefix to others and we
couldn't talk about a slightly different
model just called contextual online
pause discovery so I'm going to explain
all what these terms means in the next
few slides so starting with waterfall
security controlling you know in offline
setting in a more precise sense ok so
let's go into the offline multiple
hypothesis testing problem so you have n
hypothesis that you want to test H 1 to
H n and we assume that each of them has
a p value associated with it that's
let's not buy p1 to PN so think of the
multiple hypothesis testing procedure
our script R as a as a test that takes
these p-values and reduce and rewritten
subset of hypothesis that has to be
rejected okay so I mean I mean the
hypothesis was it could be anything like
testing for a think of a test that you
do for with the Regine is associated
with the trait ok if it a gene is
associated with the trait for example a
mutation in the gene could be associated
with the increase in height and now you
get data for this and then you test
whether this is this hypothesis is true
or false
so you basically 4 min al hypothesis
which might be saying that it is not
associated and you have an alternate and
then you see which one should be so one
either your reject or accept the null
hypothesis that's typically a test and
so this is and you might do multiple of
such tests
so baby would be helpful just to hear
sort of the problem safari okay yeah I
guess yeah I mean I guess so it is
exactly I mean like sort of so it has
this is some kind of a statistical yeah
so now the issue is if you test a lot of
hypotheses so you check for every gene
in your body whether or not it's
correlated with a particular outcome
even if your tests are reasonably
accurate just because you checked so
many different things a bunch of them
are going to spurious they look accurate
and sometimes the number of things that
will click they're correlated it is
pretty you know is some large number of
things but actually most of those things
that looked accurate according to the
test or not and so then you know your
test looks pretty useless as concerned
as you do multiple tests how do you
interpret the findings yeah I guess the
idea is that we want to get to a
procedure maybe not making false
positive discoveries you're not making
discoveries that are just curious by
chance so we want to control we want to
create a procedure then that when you do
multiple testing can control this false
positive so that's basically hypothesis
testing procedure you know multiple
hypothesis in procedure takes a bunch of
these hypotheses and returns set of
hypotheses that has to be rejected
[Music]
I mean what do you mean by I mean the
tests are independent right so the tests
are independent right so so each so even
if you do the independent test the fact
that you set it on alpha to be point
naught 5 I mean as in the previous
example I mean you could have spurious
discoveries that's just because by
chance right maybe the disconnect is
like a frequentist versus patient
perspective like the the p-value this is
telling you like a frequentist quantity
and it's the true probability of the
null hypothesis is very high and then it
might be that you know even if all them
are true you come up with a large number
that appear to be false some of this
would be avoided if you like really
understood the prior but yeah yeah I
mean that'd be changing the p-value to
make sure so I'm not gonna test the same
hypothesis multiple times in this like
I'm going to test all different genes
for correlation with yeah yeah okay so
what happened so let's maybe like looks
understand this in slow slightly this
better so let's say what are the fall
all possible outcomes that we need to
multiple hypothesis test so in the rows
there are what happens what's the truth
and this is what your test is giving you
okay so there are four possible outcomes
in this coefficient matrix I mean you
could have a hypothesis that's truly
null and you accept it that's a good
case yeah yeah that's truly alternate
and you reject it that's also good case
and when you have but you also a
mistakes
so so the notion of false discovery rate
which was introduced by this notion this
work by Benjamin Hochberg formalize this
and said what what's what should be
controlled
what's the notion that we should be
control so so let's start with the
notion of false discovery proportions
which is defined as a number of
discoveries or number of number of false
discovery so that that's B divided by
the number of rejections that's the
symbol R or one is just max the
proportion is the number of it's a
proportion of false discoveries that
you're making so now this number of
false discovery toad number of total
discoveries and this is a random
variable subject to the way there are
numbers in your in your tests and so on
and so you're looking at expected value
of this which is called FDR and that's
the notion that we get into control so
FBR could be thought of an expert in
proportion of the type 1 error looking
at the type 1 error and you're
controlling that that's okay and so in
the offline setting a Benjamin Hochberg
procedure is is a very popular way of
controlling this this FDR that's been
been studying for the last third if I
use now
[Music]
I mean so this is I mean again this is
not a dev looking at the leg this is the
problem with multiple tests it's not
looking at the optimality of tests or
anything I mean this is you're not
asking me anything what the tests per se
you're just saying that you you're
multiple of these tests and you want to
find prevent the number of spurious
discoveries it's not really married to
optimality of these so the other side of
this problem is also this notion of
statistical powers because you really
don't want like I mean is easy to
control 50 are look similarly as is easy
to control privacy so you also want to
talk about utility so the this the
notion of utility in this concept would
be the power statistical power of these
days so while we want to control FDR we
also want to increase the power so the
power is an um the number of the true
discoveries that you're making the
number of null hypothesis that are truly
truly rejected there are number of
alternate ideas is that truly accepted
so that's the the true discovery
proportion that's defined as the s which
is the which is alternate is true and
you reject it I divided by N 1 which is
alternate static truth and again this is
a random variable and the expected value
of this is it's known as the true
discovery rate so the idea of these
entire line of work is is to basically
ensure that you control the Falls this
can be while maximizing the true
discoveries so these are the two things
that you want to come in control FDR and
you want maximizes so that's what
happens at the offline setting and so
what has what happened in the last ten
years that we move to a more online
setting where where the tests are coming
in an online fashion okay so so what's
happening is like if you are looking at
offline setting you assume that all the
hypotheses and all the tests are
available beforehand and you're
basically controlling their false
discoveries knowing all the results so
you assume that you know all the
p-values and then you control you design
it as that can't
the FDR while maximizing two discoveries
that'll happen in the real setup so in
real setup the tests are not fixed a
priori I mean you have pests that
carried one after the other let's take a
simple example maybe I mean this so
let's say the company that's doing an
a/b testing another page okay so you're
looking at whether you look through
looking at the click-through rate on a
webpage so now you might set up an
hypothesis saying that changing the
color would increase my click-through
rate will make it more likely that
people will click the page okay so based
on that result you might set another you
might create another test saying that
depending on how the color looks if I
put it on my look at a mobile ocean how
does Ana click-through rate changes so
and you might consider the sequence of
these tests based on the results of the
previous test that you already have so
that positives are not known a priori
there they come over time in a stream
and so now each time you have a new
hypothesis and you want to make decide
whether to accept or reject the
hypothesis so this is what the online
multiple testing problem is so you have
a sequence of ordered hypotheses H 1 H 2
and so on and each we're coming with
arriving in a stream with a possible
p-value P 1 P 2 and so on and at each
step you are to decide whether to reject
them the current hypothesis without
having access to hypothesis that's
coming in the future so you just have
access to what's happen in the past and
you have to decide at that movement
whether to accept or reject it again the
goal is to control the false discovery
rate and and maximize the true discovery
rate okay so what what's about changing
now is that you have this alpha the
significance level that you are that you
are designing for your test yes
we would get to that in a moment I mean
yeah you make it freeze assumptions and
that will affect the power and so online
testing procedure takes a sequence
significance level so instead of States
creating one alpha what you're going to
do is you are choosing alpha based on
what you have and what you know at this
time T so you have this alpha T at every
point T and then you're going to
basically reject or accept based on that
p value and so you compared PT that's
your p value at current time T with
respect to alpha T and if PT is less
than alpha T you reject otherwise so now
the goal is to come up with this notion
these significance levels that are a
function of all the previous decisions
that you're made at every time step T so
one can just go ahead and like define
FDR again in this online setup I mean
it's almost the same they said that you
have this time subscript added out so
the default is create proportion is
basically number of false objections
they were divided by number of
rejections and the expected value of
that is if they are at time T and you
want the supremum of this overall time
step that's the goal in our online setup
so the challenge here is that you don't
know what's happening in the future you
have to basically except dataset reject
based on what you have seen so far okay
and then we can similarly define true
discovery rate in online setting so
there is so as I said this this problem
was introduced about ten years back by
the work of Foster Einstein and there
has been like some good work in the last
few years of creating rules or
procedures that I'd do online false
discovery rate control a general class
of this rules is known as generalized
alpha investing I'll get to this in a
next few slides so there and there was a
specific instance which instantiation of
this your life I'll find resting this
there's a technique called s Lord
level based on recent discovery and
there's sub technique called a slot plus
plus we just recently came so these are
all specific sub examples of this notion
of generalize alpha investing that we'll
get to in there's also a slightly
different technique also
and again this is slightly tangential to
this this discussion this line of work
so I'm going to not discuss that but if
your questions I can talk about this
because it's this is based on something
called a stories procedure which is a
different different variant of many
Hochberg procedure but let's focus on GA
I shall I shall find this thing so so
what is contextual insinuations I did I
did started with offline hypothesis
testing we've into the online model and
now I need to add this word contextual
so what is contextual information here
so what happens is that typically when
you do these tests in addition to the
p-values you also have some side
information I mean you might have that
you have related to the test and this
inside information or contextual
information is there something that you
can utilize to make your test better so
I mean I guess roughly you can think of
contextual information as some indirect
information that measures the likelihood
of hypothesis that is just had been
false but you don't really know the
relationship ahead of time so it is some
indirect indicator of the hypothesis
being false but you just don't know that
information what the relationship is
exactly a priori this could be any
information so let's maybe Helen has
these questions let's make it more
concrete so let's take some examples and
see what what could be a side
information in different setups so we
were talking about a/b testing of the
webpage and you're looking for the cult
changes in colors and effect on flick
through rate but the site information
could be the size of your banner ad or
the contact content on the text on the
page right I mean these are all site
information which are not directly
relevant to the question that you're
asking about the quasi color is
influencing the click-through rate but
it could be information that could be
play a role in your analysis we
discussed about gene with the trait so
the really important questions about
whether a mutation in a gene is causing
a trait please so I mean that's the
question that you're looking at and
you're looking at the correlations of
this gene with the trait but it could
matter that the location of the gene
would play a role or count of the genes
or chromosomes could play a role in
general like there are motions of like
machine learning and problems of disease
prediction and you're looking at how
other person is predisposed to a
particular disease and then the magical
information of a person could play a
role I mean so that's it's a great
question for example like I mean this is
it this is something that the test
person I mean the investigator would
would be doing this I mean like so what
what's happened for example in the in
the gene studies I mean that the general
problems are looking at correlations I
mean they would just look at
correlations of them with a mutation a
mutation of a gene with the height for
example that's very thing and that's the
test that you're doing I mean you could
design a different test but like you can
use already the conditional information
twe to influence the test
yeah this me this what we are not going
to be discussing how do you decided
conditional information but at the fact
that condition information is given to
you some through some way let me that's
okay maybe like concretely like the way
like to compute a p-value you have to
know the distribution of your test
statistic if your no hypothesis is true
and so there's a lot of reason to
formulate a simple null hypothesis so
that you can calculate that even though
you might prefer to have all of the
contextual information that would make
it look like it's just one else is too
hard there's a long line of work in the
offline setting in utilizing conditional
information I think and this is this is
anything some amusing connections to
also the adapter data analysis and so on
so what's called contextual online
multiple hypothesis testing and so it's
a problem where you have a sequence of
hypotheses that are having in a stream
again so instead of now in addition to
the p-value you also have this this
contextual vector coming from some
contextual space that is that issue
information that you have
so again the goal is the same at each
point I you have each year to decide
whether to accept or reject on the
hypothesis null hypothesis and you want
to control the FDR and maximize the
number of true discoveries okay so the
main thing is that one thing you should
remember is that the hope is that one
can use the conditional information to
improve the number of useful discoveries
right because you can always ignore the
conditional information and just use the
p-values and use the previous procedures
to do control FTR so though the the the
main thing to think about is that
hopefully the conditional formation is
going to help you improve the number of
true discoveries so what changes of that
doubt your your alpha t the significance
level at each time step is now a
function of not only you've previously
actions but also the function of a
conditional information so you have this
X vector that's coming up every time and
your alpha T is defined as a function of
all these things and but the things
remain same so you will define it alpha
t and then you check with your PT and if
it is less than alpha t you reject
otherwise you accept so that's the like
this like the introduction to the stock
so let's last 5-10 minutes I will
explain what the results that we achieve
in this setting okay so any any
questions about the setting so we
started with offline online and then
contextual online so so the main thing
that we want to focus is that we first
want to show that there's empty our
control
I mean it's essential step and as I said
the FBR control is only once once side
of the coin you all do we also look at
the power of these tests and hopefully
show that the conditional information
could lead to increase in power and I
don't think I'm too explodes but let's
talk about so I said so the the the way
we do a pure control is by kind of
generalizing this starting with this
notion of generalized alpha investing
rules which have been introduced by
Aronian ross set in for in the online
testing situation and we introduced a
new class of testing tools or procedure
called contextual generalized alpha
investing rule so I'm going to just
briefly explain what these rules
and then say whatever extension would be
so so if you look at those various
notion of alphai investing so it has to
do with something with investing and I
mean some money and so on so I think
that that's tidy of this journal is
alpha investing rules so what does this
do
so let's say that you have you starts
with some budget that so that's your
alpha value that you have for for your
testing procedure and the idea is that
each of these tests is going to use some
wealth of this company so you pay some
penalty for doing a test okay so after
the test you get you lose some money and
so each test will cost you some money
but each discovery you get a reward set
up so every time you do a test you you
pay something and every time you make a
discovery you earn something back so
that's a lifestyle for investing in
pictures you can mathematically define
this so you start with some initial
wealth which is a number between 0 to
alpha then you at every point you have a
wealth update so you pay a penalty
function Phi T and then you get a and a
reward if you make a rejection so the
main thing is to ensure that I mean
nothing breaks here so so you can't have
the well to be negative so the the Phi T
should be less than WT minus 1 otherwise
every time you make a discovery
so so so you invest it every time time T
and then you receive a reward only a
certain yeah yeah so the PT goes every
time but every time you make it society
is 1 or 0 based on whether you make a
rejection and if it's one you get their
work you make a decision at the time
thank you
once once it's done it's time yeah you
don't know the future also ok so there's
something backwards here so basically
one more thing that we need to do is to
make sure that you can obviously need to
control you can't give a arbitrary
amount of reward at every time because
then otherwise this problem is you can
just pick WT to be anything there has to
be some control on the wealth other word
that you can give it every point in time
and that comes through a complicated
equation I mean we won't have time to go
through it but it in a way it comes to
when you do then lies in your life this
proof of this control so the goal would
be to construct the function fee cyan
alpha so they all lie in the Sigma field
of these a variety minus 1 that's
basically the previous positions that
you mean so what happens in this in with
the contextual information is that you
basically change the Sigma field so
you're changing your instead of just the
previous discoveries you also have these
contextual information that you have
that you have to and I mean that's so
that is what we define as contextual
generalize alpha interesting rules the
Sigma field of these so it's just even
that's something that we get realize
so the main the one more thing that we
need to add is this notion of
monotonicity which is a conceptually as
a simple rule to say that that if you
are making more rejections then your
threshold should be significance level
should be more that's like a simple
additions conflict that we need to add
so in addition to the previous
constraints we also had this
monotonicity and then basically what you
can shows that if the p-values are
independent and the crucial thing is
that the p-values are and XT s are
independent under the null then any rule
from this class would would satisfy a PL
control so the point to note is that I
mean the PS and the exes could be
arbitrarily related under the alternate
they are only required to be independent
under the null so under the alternate I
mean obviously the otherwise is no
really I think that you can control for
so so the they are only dependent and
independent under the null they could be
arbitrary related at under the alternate
and this is but this is not the only
thing you can show you can show actually
you can relax the you don't have to be
PS to be independent you can show weaker
assumptions on the p-values of super
uniformity P ideas you can have actually
arbitrary dependence on p-values I mean
you obviously have to be more
conservative in that case I think that
the theorem that we're going to show
later on but I mean that would be the
goal I mean I mean we would get to in
those slides and but yeah so the idea is
that yeah so you FBI control is
something that's possible under the
context all information by changing this
by creating this any monotone
conditional is alpha is investing dual
keep the proof idea and so basically
gets get into the second part of this
talk I mean so so as I said the FBI
control is just one piece of the puzzle
I'm going to stop quickly about what
can do with that I mean I guess the
point is to ensure that you have
increase in statistical power and the
answer is yes and they'd come to the big
asteroid so because it's really hard to
analyze statistical power in vacuum I
mean this is this is true for any test
not just our test one has to define a
set of pieces and you can only analyze
power in those under those conditions so
so we are to define set of rules and
define the model and the conditions
under which these hold there will be
three pieces that we have to define for
this to happen so quickly what happens
is that the way we define our set of
rules is is basically define a specific
subclass of these contextual generalized
alpha interesting where we are going to
use the current context to define a wave
function so we're going to convert the
excess into a bait and we are going to
weigh the significance level using this
wave function so you can look at
subclass of these this general class of
rules where this specific thing happens
and we're going to focus on something
known as lord lord is a lord is a
popular subclass of these inlets alpha
investing rules and what we are going to
do is we are going to define a mixture
model a pretty general mixture model
there which the main thing to notice is
that we're going to assume that the the
X's have different probability
distribution under the null and the
alternate and we will have some
conditions on these mixture
distributions
the idea here is the context gives you a
weak signal it gives you a big signal
about the likelihood of the alternate
but you generally don't know the signals
so you don't nothing about this you know
you're assuming that X is strong from
these distributions l0 l1 and the
p-values under the alternate is coming
from some some distribution f1 sorry
yeah but you are not new idea of these
l0 cellphone or front so you really
don't know anything about them see it's
but assumption is that under the null
they're coming from the uniform under
alternate they are coming from some
arbitrary f1 context the XS are the
context the the p-values under the
alternate is defined using this so I
mean the main thing is that it captures
standard models like normal me its model
Vario texting for whether the Gaussian
has a mean zero or nonzero and the main
thing is two main thing what we show is
that like there is we define a notion of
infirmity meanness of when and sure that
if you have if you are a if your context
has some information as property then
you can have a separation between what
achieve what you achieve without using
the context and what you can achieve
with the context so you apply the same
procedure Lord without the context and
you apply the simplicity Lord with the
context and if the context have some
notion of infirmity earnest which is
really a intuitive notion which
basically says that it's debates are
higher under the alternate then you can
show separation saying that you would
achieve more power than with our context
um so you want to accept more readily
when you think the alternate has higher
you want to a reject you're gonna be
like give yourself sort of more space to
declare a discovery when you kind of
think a priori the discovery is true and
when you think every area the discovery
like the null is the case you sort of
set of more stringent standard yeah yeah
but you know but but the context has to
be have some information right I mean
the context would be independent of all
these things and yeah so you have to
have context has to somehow relate to
the alternates right otherwise there's
you obviously can't get anything so
that's is formalized this notion of
infinity owners that we define I mean I
mean it satisfies the notion of infinity
nurse we would we would say that we have
more discoveries we would theoretically
show that there's a separation in the
power bit and without using context yeah
so I think that that's I mean you so I
mean like so one thing is that this
actually helps in practice I mean so
that's that's the main thing
one nice thing about these problems is
that like once we define this in this
way I said the using the weights as a as
a weight excess as a weight function you
can define any parametric form of these
of these of these X's we impact you
something else based on neural networks
and you can train these neural networks
using X's and to disk so that the goal
would be you train these networks where
you have a hard constraint on FDR but
you want to maximize the number of
amyloid discoveries you can train these
networks in that online fashion by
imposing the FDR control constraint
subject to maximize you know discoveries
and you can like it really works
remarkably well compared to other
procedures that we know of because you
can suddenly get even like twenty to
thirty percent improvement by just using
this
see so to them this is running out of
time so they're the ideas that we
introduced this
I mean concept of context or online FDR
control and it proposed a new class of
tools that do that I mean just a little
analysis of their control and power in
form power improvement bit better
performance so one thing that we have
been done I think is really interesting
is that this notion of infirmity owners
is a really a condition on the
distributions and it's not clear how you
can do that in practice I mean how do
you check for these whether you in
impact is whether you have intermittent
is is satisfied and the procedure based
on your network I mean we don't have any
proof of convergence did I get you
correct I'm trying to now summit which
you said that contextual data actually
improve the quality of your inferences
where quality basically means asking how
did actually would relate to a
contextual integrity and actual
integrity and then rephrase the question
completely differently because I heard
you say somewhere in the beginning that
when statistical power goes up utility
goes up yes the utility is defined in
terms of statistical power right I mean
so that that's because I think whether
there is utility is a question you can't
answer with computing
and also not assume so you can if you're
doing research you can say okay that's
gonna be my assumption of course no
problem but as soon as that we shirt
goes out into the world the question
whether the significance going up is the
utility I think the goal is a goal of
science in general is to make
discoveries right I mean you want to
find whether whether the whether the
drug is that's a very dangerous
assumption and in this conference I
think that is very important not to fall
into that trap so computational models
that you want to make to say I'm gonna
shoot this but as soon as you take this
you will have to engage with people who
actually ask
[Applause]
all right so we're really lucky to have
a car speaking here